hey everybody Welcome to roll back what
is rollback well rollback is essentially
my way of introducing awesome Evergreen
episodes from the prehistoric pre-video
days of the podcast to YouTube for the
first time these are powerful and
enlightening conversations that I really
think deserve a second life here on
YouTube and my interview with Michelle
mcmackin MD is one prime example board
certified in Internal Medicine Dr
mcmackin is the executive director of
nutrition and lifestyle medicine for New
York City Health and hospitals and she
specializes in plant-based nutrition
specifically what is perhaps uniquely
inspiring about Dr mcmackin is her
commitment to studying evidence-based
nutritional protocols and then applying
that practical knowledge to faculty to
colleagues and resident doctors so in
other words she's of course devoted to
educating her patients but also to her
fellow medical professionals about
healthy plant-based nutrition filling is
very much needed Gap in our current
system of medical education
the bottom line is this we need more
doctors like Dr mcmackin and I'm just
delighted to share our exchange with you
today this is a highly informative
conversation I really hope you enjoy it
from episode 162 recorded way back in
2015 this is me and Dr Michelle mcmackin
so I work at Bellevue Hospital I don't
know if you or your listeners are
familiar with it well all I know about
Bellevue is like that was the insane
asylum that's usually the first conjured
image of like Bellevue where they lock
you up right yeah that's usually the
first
um thing people think of so I have to
spend time kind of dispelling that yeah
this uh idea of the Iron Gate yeah so um
Bellevue is uh it's actually the
nation's oldest continuously operating
hospital and it's also the oldest public
hospital so it's how old like when like
17 something wow yeah is there is the
original structure still wow yeah
um so and you know I think the key
things to know about it are it's an
extremely Mission oriented place so in
being a safety net hospital we
basically take care of everybody
regardless of ability to pay right and
um
and the people that that kind of
Hospital attracts like the the doctors
and the nurses and the other stuff that
it attracts are people that I feel like
I'm a lot in common with so more service
oriented exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah but
it's right in it's like on the east side
isn't it it's on 27th and 1st and so
it's it's so my practice is it's a
primary care practice I'm trained in
Internal Medicine which is basically
like um you know you're the person that
takes care of sort of everything so
you're taking care of the whole body
you're taking care of all the organ
systems Mental Health
you know so like a lot of social stuff
you're kind of the quarterback of like
the
Healthcare team right right right so do
you have a like a private practice
outside of the hospital or is your
office your office is in the hospital oh
Bellevue it's not the time so if
somebody comes to see you is it like uh
like an acute situation like an ER
situation or because I mean it's not
usual for somebody to book an
appointment and go to a hospital to see
a doctor right so um so there's a very
large ambulatory care practice as part
of Bellevue Hospital so we're it's a
regular doctor's office
um
there's Internal Medicine there's OB GYN
there's all the Medical Specialties
surgical Specialties
um so basically coming to see me is like
going to see it like any visit to the
doctor right you're just like your
general practitioners right situation
right right so I take care of adults
only that's internal medicine and um and
yeah I mean I basically take care of
people from all walks of life so you
know I'll have
most of my most of my practice is
actually Spanish speaking because I
speak Spanish and
um but it really a day doesn't go by
where I'm not on The Interpreter phone
in like Tibetan or West African dialect
or Chinese dialect French polish so it's
an extremely diverse
a patient population and in terms of
education and literacy there's a huge
amount of diversity as well but in
general I would imagine kind of lower on
the socio-economic scale right I think
that's you know there we have people
from you know coming from all walks of
life but yeah I mean most of my patients
have either no insurance at all or are
have a government-sponsored insurance
like Medicaid and if somebody comes in
with no insurance there's no you still
treat you still treat them and then
that's what we're there for right yeah
it's awesome so everybody gets basically
state-of-the-art care like they have
this access to 100 of the same Services
you'd have anywhere and are they afraid
they're going to get locked up in the
Looney
get in a straight jacket they don't
express that to me but is that aspect of
the hospital still exists though like
well is that just some kind of wives
tale or I mean that must be rooted in
some kind of reality back in the day
yeah I mean it has I think Bellevue I
don't want to miss quote but I think
Bellevue has one of the largest number
of inpatient patient
psychiatric beds and so it has a long
tradition of treating mental health
right issues
but like that was what it kind of
originally made its name yeah doing
right but like you know Bellevue is also
a leader in you know TB back in the day
tuberculosis and even now like in the
90s when TB came back
um Ebola you know we've done amazing
things with treating Ebola patients wow
that's interesting so so was that was
Bellevue kind of front and center when
that recent sort of scenario very front
and center wow so what was that that was
us that must have been pretty you know
interesting and heightened yeah it was
intense I think there was a lot of
um
there is a tremendous amount of fear
obviously around it and you'd hear
things I mean just even being in New
York like you'd hear you'd overhear
conversations on the subway about oh you
know this person who had Ebola was in
the bowling alley in Brooklyn and I was
there the day before and right there's
just one guy was a doctor right was he a
doctor at Bellevue no I remember that
story yeah wow but we uh we treated him
and it was a huge success obviously and
now we're sort of a flagship hospital
for future potential future Ebola cases
so were there like medical practitioners
walking around in hazmat suits in the
hospital and stuff or is that like a
like a closed off it was a very very
yeah very closed off very controlled
situation extremely well thought out
um because obviously the consequences
are of not thinking out well are pretty
strong right so how did you end up at
Bellevue like where did you go to
medical school and what kind of Led You
Into You Know towards your path yeah so
um I went to med school at Columbia here
in New York and uh
then I trained you know it's kind of at
during med school I actually originally
set out to do Public Health work and
then
um pretty early on in my training
realized I wanted to uh essentially like
treat asthma in the Bronx like do very
basic primary care for people who
otherwise may not have it and um I feel
like I could probably have the most
impact that way and it used my own skill
set the best
um and so I went into training in
Internal Medicine I trained at Cornell
actually
um Cornell here in the city in Manhattan
yeah yeah well Cornell Medical Center
and then graduating from residency or
finishing residency I uh looking for a
job I knew I wanted to be at an academic
center basically you know for me it was
like the mission of service but also the
mission of teaching so Bellevue was a
really perfect fit because obviously the
mission of service and then Bellevue is
a teaching hospital for NYU so
my typical week looks like
you know half the time I'm seeing
patients in the office and then the
other half the time I'm teaching I'm
basically residents or doctors in
training are coming to me they're seeing
patients and they're presenting you know
their plan or their assessment to me and
I'm giving them feedback so right right
yeah I want to get into all of that but
like just sort of sticking with the the
evolution of Dr mcmackin
um my only point of reference is is law
school and I know from my experience in
law school that you know sort of when
you when you enter law school there's a
lot of people who are kind of service
oriented and they're like I'm gonna go
work for this non-profit or you know
this pro bono you know organization or
something like that and then you know by
year three everybody's shipping off to
the Associates at Big prominent law
firms with big you know sort of salaries
and and the rationale is generally like
I'm in so much debt you know I'm just
gonna go do this for a couple years and
then I'm gonna go do you know what makes
my heartbeat and more often than not
that you know so sort of doesn't happen
you know you get stuck in into that
lifestyle I mean is that similar is it
similar in medical school I mean do you
see that kind of attrition yeah I think
well I mean you brought up the debt
issue and I think that's a real it's a
very real driver of a lot of people's
choices
um in terms of what they specialize in
and how they formulate their practice
um
and it probably should have been an
issue for me but I just I just said you
know I just went straight to the what
made my heart right like where where
does that come from I mean is that did
your parents raise you well like how
does it how do you definitely did you
know where does the kind of compulsion
to to be in service derive from if you
had to articulate that yeah I mean
um I'd like to say it's you know it's
like I'm born with a noble impulse but
really I just feel like you know you can
be in service in a lot of different ways
right I mean you can be within medicine
and it you don't have to have a practice
at a hospital that serves the
underserved to be in service of others
of course
um well by its very nature it's just
you're in service just by being a doctor
right right and
um
but I think for me there's something
about
um
being and being the person that has the
opportunity to
offer something where no where maybe
someone else wouldn't have the chance
you know they wouldn't have the chance
to get that so for example a lot of my
patients I'm you know I'm the first
doctor that has ever sort of called them
back with their lab results for example
I mean that sounds crazy right I mean
you go to the doctor and don't you
expect a call saying you know like your
blood work was good or this is a problem
and so time after time when I call my
patients back with their lab results
they're like you're the best doctor ever
I can't believe you called me and I just
think about doing the thing that you're
kind of supposed to do right and so I
guess what I'm getting at is
um it feels really good to be
to be offering that to people I mean
people deserve that right people deserve
that kind of relationship and um and I'm
also it's just it's just a great
platform to educate people about things
that are really important to their
health and to me
um which I know we'll get into yeah I
mean it seems like there's kind of a you
know systemic problem when it comes to
just basic patient care and palliative
care right like like just general rules
of human decency you know seem to get
cast aside and I don't know whether
that's because you know it's a numbers
game and you're just seeing so many
patients or or what kind of happens but
you know the typical patient experience
is not always so positive particularly
when it comes to you know sort of
bedside manners and all of that
yeah I think um and we'll probably get
into this but I think
um the system is broken in a lot of ways
and the system doesn't really
allow us as Physicians to interact with
patients I think the way we probably
should and you know you know it takes
time to it takes time to deliver
individualized care and to call people
back with their lab results and yet time
there's no reimbursement for that and so
therefore time isn't carved out for that
and that's understandable at the
Hospital level or you know and it's not
just our hospital it's every medical
system
um for the most part right I think it's
you know easy to just say oh well you
know they're selfish or there's some
kind of God complex with doctors but I
think when you really look at the system
and what's driving it and what's pushing
them like they're just trying to like
get through the day right you know
they're good people it's like you you
have to be you know of a certain mindset
to even get into this to begin with so
right that's why you know I said it's
systemic I think I think it's just the
structure within you know the rules that
apply to practicing don't really
necessarily provide for that yeah I
completely agree I completely agree cool
so um all right so you're up Bellevue
but at the same time you're a professor
right at NYU Professor come on thanks
for the promotion
okay that's just semantics
you're a college professor or a medical
school not a school of medicine right so
and and so tell me what you teach at NYU
so most of my teaching goes on at the
level of The Residency so
um those are so basically people that
have graduated from medical school so
the fully fledged doctors but um who are
in their training program and um some of
it is didactic
but the vast majority majority of it is
really just Hands-On clinical
day to day how do you take care of
patients right
um so you're walking these like new
doctors through the kind of daily
routine of what it means to be a
resident yeah and you're just you're
watching you're watching what they do
with a Eagle Eye you are ultimately the
one responsible for the care that
they're delivering
so you are you're you're trying to help
them learn
and yet make it a beneficial situation
for the patient obviously and so you're
balancing practicing medicine with
assistant professor duties I mean that's
a that's a lot right so I mean what's a
what's a typical day or a typical week
look like yeah I mean it's it's
direct patient care so me sitting down
in my office in my exam room and seeing
patients for half a day and then in the
afternoon for example I would then
move to a larger area where residents or
doctors in training come to me and
present cases in other words they'll
they'll see a patient they'll come up
with their own assessment they'll
present the whole situation to me and
I'll say hey that you know I think
you're You're On Target here right I
like your plan kind of like a doctor
house kind of yeah only only there's
very there's there's not as many
Mysteries it's not quite that exciting
um there's definitely some mystery but
that's in the same hot so you're in the
same hot you're not going to anyway like
a different building same same exact
area yeah interesting
um
so yeah like I said I mean most of the
most of the time it's a very Hands-On
practice um and there's there is
didactic stuff but it's mostly just
Hands-On
um
exciting people and uh and so let's get
into kind of the plant-based yeah slant
good where you're coming from I mean
where did you know what's the origin
story there like how did you get
interested in plant-based nutrition and
you know where did that begin
yeah I mean
looking back I mean I think it really
there's almost like two parallel roads
um
that I've been on that it didn't really
converge until fairly recently so
um the professional story which is a
little bit less interesting
um we've kind of already gone through
some of it but
you know I um I went to college I was an
English major English literature major
um
graduated at the height of their
recession in the 90s like did odd jobs
worked at a used bookstore
um eventually so you didn't know the
doctor thing wasn't no part of it that
was not experience not at all you
weren't like a driven type A pre-med
person I was a driven type a person but
not premium but not pre-med yeah
interesting I mean I
I took a semester of chemistry in
college because my dad's a biochemist
and I felt like I've got to just honor
that you know
and my mom is too so I felt like how did
you do I actually did well but then I I
didn't take the whole year I just was
like you know I've done it I proved that
I can take a half a science class and
Excel at it and now I'm a liberal arts
person yeah I'm a Humanities person I
love you know I love novels I love the
story
um but then graduation happened and I
was like oh whoops you know I need a job
like what so
um
eventually
um I lived in Atlanta at the time after
graduation and I eventually just
stumbled on a job at the Centers for
Disease Control down there as a writer
editor and I worked there for about
three years in my early 20s and that was
that was the experience that got like
the gears turning around going to med
school
and yet I still had not taken a science
class right interesting so so at CDC I
mean that must have been like that's a
crazy Place yeah right yeah it's an
intense place
um well it's like a cross between
intensity and like government you know
the government your environment yeah
um but yeah I mean people do amazing
stuff they go out on outbreaks I mean
they're the folks that are dealing with
ebola like we were talking about before
and all kinds of stuff
um so it was pretty inspiring and that's
where I thought you know hey you know
this is
completely unexpected but maybe I should
consider getting involved and
knowing that that kind of decision was
at least a 10-year commitment and I was
already at that point whatever right and
you had 25 I hadn't taken all the
prerequisites in college right for Med
schools so how did you have to you had
to go back and kind of do that right
yeah I did I did a post Baccalaureate
Pre-Med program and
um those programs are great because
you're surrounded it's like you and 24
other Humanities majors
who made this decision you were all
questioning exactly like what am I doing
I can't believe you know I'm doing this
and um the one I went to it um in
Goucher College in Baltimore was great
because you took every pre-med
prerequisite in one year like wow
chemistry organic chemistry physics and
biology all in one year and uh it's like
I like it's like ripping off a Band-Aid
like just get it over with right that's
intense and yet I loved it I didn't I
you know I actually found out that I was
really good at science and um my parents
were pretty proud yeah I was gonna say
your dad must have been happy right yeah
he was oh I finally understood what he
did yeah I could finally understand like
his Publications you know not completely
so he's he's like a lab scientist he's
an academic biochemist yeah so he does
um he does a lot of work with um gene
replication DNA replication right and
and here you are uh expressing yeah
it comes out yeah this recessive gene
that now is coming to coming to be
expressed right well my mom has it too
so yeah yeah she's a scientist as well
yeah she's a biochemist this was
inevitable no doctors no doctors in the
family
um so yeah so then I you know I've
finished up that program and I moved to
New York
um
got a you know a great like one year
position in at the Department of Health
um as a health educator here in New York
and then that year I applied to med
school and within about a week of moving
to New York I realized I was never going
to leave like just love it you love it
love it here yeah so
um enrolled at Columbia and um I like
how you just said you just enrolled just
just several yeah because I just decided
to yeah well it's interesting looking
back on your resume like even though you
had this you know Humanities background
with the CDC and then working in public
health in New York and then having all
the prerequisites I mean that's a pretty
solid basis to get into a good med
school and Columbia was great because
there were a lot of other postbacks
there too so it felt like a community
and it felt
um I think there's something about
there's a lot of things about being a
Humanities major and going to med school
and starting med school at the age of 27
which to me now sounds young but at that
time you know you're whatever you're six
years older than everybody else yeah
which is a big difference at that time
in your life
um
but I think for me being a Humanities
major really kept me on my Edge because
I always thought you know how am I going
to compete as far as like passing tests
and with people that were you know
molecular biology majors and
um
the first couple years were you know I I
did well but it was I really put a lot
of work in
um and then
towards the clinical years which are the
third and fourth years of med school
where you actually start talking to
patients
um that's where everything just kind of
like blew up in a great way like I was
like this has really been the right
decision you know yeah you just realize
like this is what you're made to do yeah
yeah
so um so that's sort of the we kind of
covered the
professional yeah how we got here yeah
how we got here
um and then I think the personal story
you know just leading up to to where I
am now as far as nutrition and
plant-based you know plant-based eating
you know I think I'm I'm one of those
people who probably like a lot of you
know a lot of people or kids are sort of
don't have the
um it seems a little strange to make a
distinction between you know the food on
our plate and the animals that we see
right and so I was kind of like one of
those people that never lost like that
just kind of it seemed a little bit
strange like that the food on my plate
used to be an animal that was running
around I never kind of lost that sense
that it was weird and but you weren't
like somebody who was like you know a
vegan animal rights activist in high
school or something no I I became a
vegetarian at a really young age at like
13. mostly because it just intuitively
felt like I just couldn't imagine that I
was eating the food that you know like I
was eating an actual being that used to
run around it just didn't seem it just
didn't seem right and it didn't um it
just didn't resonate with me so
I was a vegetarian for I've been a
vegetarian for a very long time and I
think you know when you're a vegetarian
in the 1980s
you you gotta you got a like very
quickly you realize you got to learn
something about nutrition because you're
gonna be asked a lot of stuff and and
it's not like your parents do you have
brothers and sisters or they do you do I
have two sisters
um I think we
three of us
um my mom and my younger sister and I
sort of all made this leap around the
same time so I had a lot of support yeah
yeah
in support of you or it was like a
collective decision it was a collective
sort of seren you know just we all kind
of I may have been the first one but it
they followed pretty quickly after and
not necessarily in support of me but
where did you grow up Baltimore
Baltimore okay yeah yeah interesting so
all right so you had some support in the
house but maybe not you know in the in
the hallways at in high school
not a lot of support in the hallways of
high school but not not like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say I had I was
excessively ridiculed or you know it was
just kind of like I think for people
it was just kind of a an anomaly that
was curious but not people kind of let
me do my thing right but it wasn't
driven by Health considerations no at
that time it was just sort of a an
ethical glitch that you felt like needed
to yeah it was just you know it was just
being a just living sort of
living in line with my values I guess
and so where does that at what point
does that you know lifestyle sort of
intersect with you know your your
medical issue I am now yeah
um it's so it it did not intersect for a
very long time and actually I was you
know continued being a vegetarian and
um went through college and all this
stuff in between before med school and
med school and then residency training
and all this time didn't really change
my eating pattern didn't really
um
use use what I knew about sort of the
growing understanding of health benefits
around being vegetarian to translate
that to my patients it was just kind of
like this is a personal choice I'm going
to kind of keep it to myself and just
you know like
keep working and right but along the way
you're educate you had mentioned like
early on you started to you took it upon
yourself to kind of educate yourself
about how to do it in a healthy way yeah
yeah absolutely I mean you had to I mean
you really I think at that point you
really had to I mean I definitely had my
like you know naders where I would be
eating like white rice and cheese at you
know in the college dorm but things
weren't like they are today but I
definitely educated myself a lot and
what were the sources of Education back
then like what were the books that were
available yeah uh you're right I mean
there wasn't certainly wasn't the
internet and
um I think you know there were there
were like a couple of guides out but
in your kind of kind of kind of winging
it but then as I got to med school and
residency there was more stuff out there
but again it really wasn't
um
it really wasn't a huge priority in the
sense of
something that I took upon myself to
learn a great deal and then translate to
my patients I think I think you you know
at the same time I was starting to
realize you know how little I knew about
nutrition in general and how little
doctors are trained because a we didn't
have any nutrition classes in med school
and then in residency I remember
um you know for example having
you know seeing a patient that had a new
diagnosis of diabetes and then going
back to present the case to my
supervisor back then and saying you know
this is the situation and they would say
okay well why don't you just talk to
them about like what to eat and so that
they don't have to go on pills and I
would go back to the room and like knock
on the door and go in and say hi
um and not have any idea what to tell
them like I have no idea and and that
struck me as being really bad right so
let's park it here for a minute because
you know it brings up so much about the
you know our system of medical education
and how we train doctors and you know
it's something that I've talked about
quite a bit on the podcast which is this
you know kind of appalling you know
scenario in which we're not training
doctors on nutrition like irrespective
of whatever your dietary proclivity is
the simple fact that there is no formal
education in nutrition whatsoever for
aspiring doctors is just such a gaping
hole like it's so crazy it really is you
know
I think so zero there was there there
was some did you have electives like
I've talked to other doctors like oh
maybe a couple hours or I had to take
this one thing but it was really nothing
unless I'm unless I'm completely like
just repressing it or not remembering it
I don't think we had any and I think
that I think I think the figure is
something like 25 of Med schools are one
in every four med school does not meet
the recommended number of hours of
nutrition and the recommended number of
hours is something like 25. for your
whole four years yeah but that
recommendation isn't like
set and it's not like a prerequisite
right it's just recommended right so the
medical schools don't have they can
choose to follow that or not is that how
it works I believe so I believe so I
think that's starting to change but um I
think I think the other issue is that
what is taught in those nutrition
classes or those hours of nutrition
teaching
um I'm not really sure I mean I I know
that you know a lot of Med schools teach
people and even residency programs teach
people about like you know vitamin
deficiencies and stuff that you're
probably never going to see unless you
practice somewhere outside the United
States
right that's what Garth Davis was
telling me like oh you know first
scenarios that arise like if someone has
gout or like just rare condition more
super rare conditions where they have
like an extreme deficiency yeah I mean
I'm not like I haven't seen scurvy in my
whole career like you know I mean I and
or maybe I haven't I just didn't
recognize it but I I think that I I
think
I think the most I mean what my mission
is and what I think people what doctors
need to learn is just nutrition to
prevent and treat the chronic diseases
that were taking care of all the time I
mean you have to understand that like a
typical day for me is
diabetes high blood pressure high
cholesterol gout kidney stones
heart disease Alzheimer's you know
everything is related to diet
so the fact that we just Echo what
you're saying I mean the fact that we
don't we're not given the training to
use what is
almost universally acknowledged as
probably the most powerful tool is is
crazy that is crazy that is crazy
but you are doing something interesting
to change that yeah so you have this uh
this grant right to teach or to do a
study and then teach medical profession
professionals about nutrition is that
accurate yeah yeah that's accurate so
let's talk about that yeah so if I can
back up I'll tell you sort of what got
me to that point which is um yeah we're
all over the place in the time but
that's okay that's okay I'm sure
everyone's keeping up just press rewind
um so yeah I mean I think that you know
it wasn't my practice was still even
though I value this stuff so much my
practice was still very like pill based
and very treating symptoms based until a
couple years ago and I have to talk
about this because it was such a
breakthrough moment for me I went to um
I know I had some conference money and I
was like what's a great con for medical
conference I can go to and I googled
um lifestyle change on a whim and the
first hit was uh American College of
Lifestyle medicine was having their
annual meeting and as I
I signed up for it I went to the
conference and
it was a huge turning point in my career
because it was a group of I don't know
400 or 500 other health professionals
mostly doctors that are interested in
using lifestyle to prevent and treat
disease
um and then the speakers at the
conference were so inspiring you know I
heard Dean ornish Neil Barnard Michael
Greger who's hilarious and so smart and
just captivating and
um you know a number of other great
speakers and and I remember the first
day of the conference being just feeling
like I was zinging
like I went back to my hotel room after
the conference and just like was reading
articles and emailing stuff and felt
like a manic episode was coming on I
mean it just like I finally had found it
it took me realizing there's a whole
community of people interested in the
same thing and seeing these inspiring
speakers and
um
I think the second day I sat down for
lunch like the conference lunch and I
sat down and looked across the table and
it was called will esselstein was
sitting there and like T Colin
Campbell's son who co-wrote The China
Study so it was just one inspiration
after another how many years had you
been a doctor at that point
um I want to say eight wow so we'll
eight after yeah eight after my training
after so a lot of years many many years
yeah and you're on you know in some
respect you're already living this
lifestyle you're interested in these
things right and yet completely unaware
that this world with all of these you
know incredible people exists out there
who are you know trying to change the
system in a certain regard and that was
news to you right and I that's amazing
well and I was also running I mean I've
been I still do run an obesity Clinic I
run a weight management clinic and I run
it on lifestyle change
um but I think that the you know when
I'd gone to National like obesity
conferences there's not there was I
remember one that I went to there was
not a single mention of food not a
single mention
and how is that even possible I know
right well I mean to be Pharaoh I think
it was a bariatric you know a weight
loss surgery based conference but still
you still have to eat and it still
matters right I mean Garth always talks
about all those because he goes to all
those those conferences on bariatric
surgery and obesity and I guess you know
what he says is that they're they're
really pushing kind of the the high
protein you know high fat low carb diet
but then he always takes pictures of the
breakfast yeah the conference and it's
just you know massive amounts of bacon
and eggs crazy you know all kinds of
crazy you know High saturated fat foods
and all this sort of stuff and he's like
this is what they're serving at the
conference on Obesity and bariatric
surgery why are people why are people
unpacking weight loss from chronic
disease like I don't understand it why
are you using
you know foods that promote chronic
disease just because in the short term
they might help with weight loss and and
not and they don't even necessarily
always do that either right um yeah I
think there's confusion about the
difference between weight loss and
health
yeah you think or I well I think that um
certainly you know certainly there's an
argument to be made that
for if you are obese and probably if
you're overweight you you know losing
weight is beneficial but I I think
you know a it's about we'll probably get
into this but hey it's about
sustainability right and B it's about
what are you know what you're doing to
lose weight all those approaches are not
equal in terms of chronic disease
prevention so
for some people I mean there's such a
desperation around weight loss which is
completely understandable that I do
think people separate that out
well I guess if you're you know if
you're in a in a critical situation that
weight loss takes priority over
everything else right like critical
meaning like you have a wedding coming
up no I know I mean if you weigh 400
pounds and you're looking at you know
blood markers that are really bad it's
like you got to get the weight off right
so you know listen you know Atkins or
those kind of Protocols are very
effective at doing that but but that's
not necessarily the healthiest way or
the most sustainable way to do it but
you'll lose the weight right well you
know unless you switch your lifestyle to
something that you can sustain you're
going to gain it back right and I've
seen that met you know many like
literally hundreds of times
um
so yeah I went to this you know I went
to this conference I was completely
energized I remember coming back that
Monday morning after the conference like
my first my nine o'clock patient was
this patient with uncontrolled diabetes
and her sugars were you know in the 200s
all the time
um which is very high and
she was already maxed out on all her
pills and I think like you know
literally four days before I probably
would have said okay you got to go on
insulin
and but that morning I just remember
feeling so empowered to say to her like
let's sit down and talk about what
you're eating and go through it and it
sounds so obvious right but but it the
Paradigm that we that most doctors
practice in
is is it doesn't a it doesn't support
that and we're not we're just not
trained to think about it that way so
um so as I started incorporating this
stuff more and more into my practice
with great success and and you know sort
of thinking like this is not you know
this I'm just one person and
I'm doing this with my patients but I
have obviously a fraction of the
patients they're being cared for at this
hospital I have a you know and uh we
have to spread this like other people
have to find out about this and I'm in a
great position to teach people because
I'm teaching people 50 of the week
so that's why I decided to apply for
that Grant
and the grant is it's a very small Grant
and it's it's a colleague and I who's
also interested in this stuff
um it's the idea is to study like take
the first year of the grant to just
study all the evidence behind different
nutritional approaches
and then in the second year to translate
that out to people in a way that's
really practical and usable and we're
going to offer it to our faculty
colleagues and to uh the resident
doctors as well right so the idea is to
actually teach medical professionals not
not average people right
it is our primary goal is that but I
think that
what I hope is that in in their learning
about it then they'll teach it back to
their patients right that's obviously
the ultimate right right but it's the
the idea is to like create a different
kind of culture right around diet and
food and lifestyle within the profession
exactly right and so how do you approach
the you know daunting Prospect of
studying different nutritional protocols
and their impact on health because
certainly there's no shortage of these
kinds of studies out there and we could
go down the rabbit hole on you know that
whole world right you know how are you
kind of approaching that yeah I mean I
it's um it really is a rabbit hole and
um I feel overwhelmed a lot of the time
and and I think if I feel that way it's
understandable that other people feel
that way and I think for me
at the
you know what I'm trying to um
what what really anchors me is the
concept that there really is
there really is Broad consensus I think
around the healthiest ways of eating
and
swear that consensus came from and I
want to look to the literature and see
you know why do people say for example
that you know whole grains are
so important why does everyone agree
that vegetables and fruits are so
important I mean it sounds we you know
people who are kind of in the know take
that for granted but I think when you're
sitting down and talking to a bunch of
medical professionals they're going to
want to know
some of the evidence not and I well and
I also think like I would say that there
is a consumer notion out there right now
that is gaining popularity that would
contravene that and say you shouldn't
eat grains and you know fruit is just as
bad as candy and you shouldn't eat that
too I mean there's so many crazy ideas
out there right so it becomes difficult
to even begin to approach you know any
of it yeah I mean I think I think that
um
you know the the media and popular
culture sort of hang on to the tensions
right and the differences
um but if if you really start looking at
most of the literature it really it it
really does there is Broad consensus
around what we should be eating and
there is a lot of overlap between paleo
and vegan or plant-based
um and we can get into why you know
reasons why I think plant-based is is my
Approach but um and I think it's a
better approach
but but there is consensus and I think
that's the main message you know that is
one message I want to impart to my
colleagues in the trainees and I think
just the power that this has to affect
change is the other message okay so if
someone's listening you know the
question that's coming into their head
right now is like all right well what is
the consensus like if you could tell me
you know let's cut through all the you
know crazy ideas on both sides of the
equation and all the warring and
infighting and all of that like what are
the you know I don't know five or six
things that you know basically the
studies that you've looked at all kind
of agree on okay number one
eliminating processed foods so by
processed because this question comes up
a lot you know when I talk to patients
what is what is a processed food so
um what I tell my patients is just eat
as close to its natural form eat food as
close to its natural form as you can
so I tell them you know if you're if
you're if it's a if it's a piece of
bread did it you know think about the
food in front of you did it grow in a
tree or from the earth you know in that
format and just keep reminding yourself
of eating in the format that's most
that's closest to the earth so processed
foods there's
a tremendous amount of evidence around
eliminating those because what we're
seeing when we're saying processed foods
are refined carbohydrates
and processed meat and those are and I
mean processed meat probably trumps
everything like if you had to tell
somebody to just eliminate one thing it
would be processed meat and again
there's broad consensus on that right
so that's hot dogs cold cuts
what are the other things yeah I'm glad
you said cold cuts because a lot of
people don't even realize that like you
get a like a deli like deli turkey
slices on like whole grain and they you
know people are that that is a processed
meat
um so bacon salami sausage
hot dogs right like you said
um
so these are very there's there's nearly
unequivocal data that these are increase
the risk of cancer and heart disease and
early deaths so that's kind of a slam
dunk refined carbohydrates probably as
bad for you as
saturated fat you know if you're going
to look at the studies and the the the
top of the list on that would be what
like crackers and you know kind of snack
foods or you know what are the what are
the worst processed carbohydrate Foods I
mean a font like white bread things like
that yeah I mean a lot of the like where
does pasta fall on that yeah I mean I
think that um you know the the white you
know sort of you take a whole grain you
remove the outer
layers that has fiber and B vitamins and
phytonutrients you're left with a
product that's
um rapidly gets converted into sugar in
your blood and causes insulin spikes and
that's the idea so examples are
you know a lot of like breakfast cereals
anything where the first ingredient is
flour or milled rice or
um
you know the white bread all the
pastries the white Rolls
um
of course like you know Soda is the
ultimate example um
right
beverage likes you know all the bottled
beverages that people drink and Ice
sweetened Iced Teas and things like that
okay so processed Meats processed carbs
yeah
broad consensus that we should be eating
more fiber
and
you know I think like you talk about all
the
you know things that were really the the
deficiency that Americans have that we
should be learning about it's not you
know it's not the vitamin deficiencies
you may learn about in med school if
you're lucky it's fiber right I mean the
average American I think it's like 15
grams of fiber a day and that's a pretty
that's a pretty pathetic amount yeah
there's some crazy stat out there that
like I don't know what it is you know 80
plus percent of people are fiber
deficient right I think it's even higher
yeah yeah but we're all worried about
protein right but like nobody's protein
right right right I uh you know you're
protein deficient if you're like not
eating enough calories right you're if
you're starving it's a starvation that's
right that's absolutely right but the
protein thing is really the big barrier
I think you know mentally for people to
kind of you know grapple with the idea
of going plant-based I mean they get a
lot of messages to to make them
concerned
um yeah everywhere you turn right and I
think people have this magical idea that
you
you know the more protein you eat the
more like basically more muscles you're
going to have and more milk and you know
I I see patients all the time who are
drinking protein shakes and they're sort
of adding that on to their normal diet
and gaining tons of weight and it's not
muscle I mean it's gonna turn to fat
right so let's talk about that like like
what is the what is what is the
implication of you know exceeding your
recommended well first of all what is
the recommended daily allowance of
protein and and what is the impact of
exceeding that in the health context
yeah so the you know I think when they
when you look at when when the Institute
of medicine came up with recommendations
on how much protein we need it was based
on nitrogen balance studies where
you kind of feed people protein and you
see how much nitrogen comes out in the
urine and you try to find a place where
you're you're neither a negative balance
or positive balance so you're getting
the protein that you need for your
normal cellular activities in your in
your day
um so the number that they came up with
for most people was about 0.6 grams for
every kilogram of body weight for the
average person and then they decided you
know let's let's round this up just to
make sure we cover everybody it's a bell
curve you know there's going to be
people at either end so let's make it
point eight and so I think people
people who look at that number if you
even look at that number think that
that's the minimum amount but really
it's actually the amount where everyone
will be getting you know the 90 I think
it's like 95 of people will be getting
the amount of protein that they need so
it's more of an it's you should think of
it more as an optimal amount
um of course there are special
situations you know in athletes and
bodybuilders and so forth where you may
need a little bit more but I think that
what the overestimation that people do
is so great and and they're already
eating more protein than they need to
begin with
um so I think it really for most people
it's a midpoint and the average the
average person that I take care of and
the average person I think in this
country is I think statistics are that
they're getting you know 70 more protein
than they need and so what happens when
you're exceeding that you know limit
so um
you know the average person yeah talking
about a bodybuilder or an endurance sure
sure so for the average person I mean
the extra protein is extra calories and
if you don't need them they will be
they'll turn to fat or you will either
metabolize them by your kidney or your
liver and get rid of them some
combination of that and
there are there is such a wealth of data
around what happens when you eat an
excess of protein and particularly
animal protein this has not been shown
for plant protein specifically
um and the the things that the totality
of the data show are that your your risk
of diabetes goes way up and and meaning
this is data from studies of hundreds of
thousands of people over years it's not
like one you know small study it's and
it's been replicated in numerous studies
so that's a big one
um almost all studies show that your
risk of heart disease goes up with
higher doses of animal protein
um
there are studies showing that mortality
goes up there's a
pretty concerning link with cancer and
you know thinking behind that
um there's this molecule called igf-1 I
don't know if you know it's insulin like
growth factor one and protein animal
protein very clearly increases this
growth factor and you do need some of
this growth factor
um but you'll make it if you eat a you
know in a recommended way and so if you
make extra of it it's very closely
linked with cancer
so I think that um and then of course
obesity which I alluded to before if you
had to select out you know the studies
show that if you have to select out one
type of food that is most associated
with waking both
cross-sectionally so like at one point
in time and over the course of you know
prospectively over the course of a
number of years it's meat
interesting because right now everybody
thinks that it's sugar it's all about
sugar right now and our kind of
reductionist culture of trying to
pinpoint one thing
um I would say that's you know Enemy
Number One right now
so when somebody comes in to your office
uh and and that's their notion I mean
I'm not defending sugar I mean sugar is
a huge problem
um how do you usually kind of you know
discuss that
yeah I'm not a fan of sugar either
um I think that I try to put it in
perspective for people so a typical
scenario might be you know a person
comes to me and they're concerned you
know they're concerned about you know
preventing diabetes and because they
have a family history or whatever and so
the first thing they'll ask me is you
know I'm TR can I should I use Splenda
instead of like a teaspoon of sugar in
my morning coffee
and if that's all the sugar they're
having in their whole day I'm not that
worried about it that's a very small
amount of sugar and I think there's a
miss people completely miss the boat
because the message isn't out there that
it's other things they're doing like the
animal proteins or refined carbohydrates
that are driving that disease risk so um
that said I also have plenty of patients
that are you know guzzling soda and
that's a pretty you know I would say in
terms of lifestyle changes to Target
it's actually a pretty easy one to help
people change so it is kind of the
low-hanging fruit of the nutrition
Counseling World just saying you know
stop drinking soap yeah yeah yeah yeah
very specific thing that everyone can
kind of understand yeah and people don't
realize I mean people are starting to
realize about soda but then I think you
know people don't realize about all the
other sugary drinks that are out there
that are just tantalizing you all the
time like everywhere the delis and the
you know the grocery stores and they
taste good and people people like them
and they don't realize that how many
calories they're getting and what
they're doing to their metabolism with
those so those that's kind of the low
hanging fruit and I always Target that
right all right well back to the protein
thing
um you're sort of we're talking about
the difference between animal protein
and plant protein I mean what about this
idea that plant protein is inferior to
animal protein that you know especially
for you know let's if you're if you're
athletic or you want to be fit or you
want to perform at your Peak there's
this idea that if you're only eating
plant proteins that you're you're really
not getting what you need in order to
you know build build muscle you know
recover quickly all these sorts of
things I mean you're you know people
like you are
it's awesome that you guys are spreading
that message and really showing people
that that's not true biochemically
that's not true
um is there any difference other than
the fact that animal protein comes with
all sorts of other things like you know
saturated fat Etc and depending upon
where you get the meat uh but with
respect to just the protein aspect of it
are there differences in bioavailability
I mean there's going to be differences
in the percentage of you know you know
essential amino acids and all of that
like I understand that but like what are
these differences and should we care no
I mean we sh we sh we should well we
should care to the extent that
when you again when you look at studies
the the evidence just trumps the fact
that we have to like animal protein is
not conducive to long-term health and
the you know if you're going to look at
the biochemical level and absorption and
synthesis and cellular function you know
you do need to get all your essential
amino acids but on a plant-based diet
you get them and it's not you know I
think there's this tendency to think
that we need to make it as easy as
possible for our bodies to get the food
but you know what sometimes it's not
good to make it as easy as possible so
if you take
if you eat a steak you know you're
getting what we call a complete protein
it has all the essential amino acids
um because it's muscle right it's it's
an animal's flesh and so you you are
necessarily getting all the the
essential amino acids but we are able to
group them together and if we get you
know some of them if we have a bowl of
you know beans and then later on we have
a whole grain you can your body has the
ability to pool it all together and in a
way that long-term studies show actually
promotes Health rather than so now
you're just crazy talking
sorry about that
um so all right so I mean basically what
you're saying is
this is a non-issue I don't want to
mischaracterize your your words but no
that was a fair characterization it's a
hundred percent a non-issue I think you
know if you're if you're trying to build
a lot of muscle and you're really you
know you're you're training and you're a
bodybuilder and you know we all you've
featured on your podcast and we all know
about you know the huge movement around
vegan bodybuilding and
um NFL stars and and so forth I mean yes
you you do need more protein but there's
no evidence to say that it's to my
knowledge that it's better in the short
term even to have animal protein and
certainly in the long term it's not
better yeah I mean all I have to go on
is my experience and then the testimony
of the people that I've spoken to or
I've had on the podcast and you know
when I talk to all these plant-based
athletes I mean they're basically
echoing what you what you're saying and
my experience is that it just it doesn't
really seem to it I don't feel like
it's impeded me you know I feel like
eating plant-based has allowed my body
to recover more quickly I mean if I
repair myself more quickly in between
workouts right and and if it's impeded
you I'd like I'd like to know what else
you could possibly do other than what
you've already done you know I I I think
that um you bring up a great point which
is it's not you know people tend to
reduce it all to to protein but what
about
um other things that are essential to
recovery and to Performance
um that you'd find in other plant Foods
how do you feel about
um this idea of you know alcohol
alkaline forming for Foods versus acid
forming foods and the impact on
metabolism
um to be honest I've never like I've
never been in that I've never gotten
swayed by that whole Acid versus
alkaline
um argument but to me it's just again
another marker for the benefits of
eating plant-based because plant Foods
tend to be alkaline and again looking at
the evidence we know that the foods that
tend to be acidic which are animal
proteins tend to cause
cause harm
so if you're if that helps you if that's
a framework that helps people understand
you know a healthy way to eat then great
they can use that you know that
framework but I to me it's just a marker
for the same concept right I mean the
idea is that by eating alkaline forming
Foods is very
um is very anti-inflammatory right as
opposed to eating acid forming foods
which
provoke inflammation and then there's
this Nexus between chronic inflammation
and all the lifestyle disease that you
alluded to before right and when you're
kind of right reducing that inflammation
in an athletic context uh it expedites
your body's ability to kind of bounce
back and heal itself there's a
definitely a connection between chronic
inflammation and illness and
um and probably lack of performance in
athletic Endeavors but
um I think that
there's more than just the acid-base
status of the food that drives
inflammation and there's a lot we don't
understand but we know that you know
even oil for example you know you
they've shown that after a very high fat
meal that's mostly animal fats
um but even also with vegetable oils
that your blood vessels ability to
um to dilate or or to open up is
impaired for about six hours so you know
there's a lot of different ways that
food can cause inflammation and I think
you know the acid-base theory or
argument is just one of them interesting
well I want to segue a little bit into
kind of
um
diet philosophies and in a more macro
sense and and you know you said earlier
that you know there's a lot of
similarities between eating plant-based
and eating paleo and there's a lot of
paleo people that listen to this podcast
and so let's talk about what those
similarities are and and what that
common ground is
yeah I mean I think the common ground is
a lack of processing of food so you know
eating Foods as close to their origin as
possible
um and focusing on vegetables and
hopefully fruits
um
Edo and eliminating Dairy obviously
that's a Common Thread there
you know the whole the whole grain
argument is one that I don't really buy
into because I think the evidence is so
strong
that eating
what we call cereal fiber
um which doesn't it's not like Special K
you know it's it's it's
fiber that comes from grains um that's
the when people do big studies that's
what they're referring to when they say
cereal fiber the evidence is so potent
um for these for this in preventing
disease for example you know when you
look at what what is the number one you
know the foods the food category that's
best at preventing diabetes it's
actually whole grains and so it kind of
turns our conventional understanding of
you know what a diabetic should avoid or
what someone should avoid on its head
right I mean because you everyone always
thinks right away right away carbs but
really those are some of the most
protective Foods so to me eliminating
that whole category is a problem well it
seems like there's a lot of
when you say grains I mean that's sort
of an umbrella term for many many things
I mean actually you know Wonder Bread or
it could mean you know some kind of
heirloom Millet you know so so you know
there's a whole there's a whole panoply
of of you know subcategories within that
and I think you know I think it is
you know okay to say or you know fair to
say that
today's wheat is you know not our
grandmother's wheat that it's highly
hybridized and you know in in certain
respects it's been stripped of much of
its nutritional value and it's growing
in soil that is not as nutritionally
dense as it once was and it's higher in
gluten and all these other things so
it's it's different you know it's
different than it once was so what grain
are we talking about where did it grow
is it sprouted is it whole or is it you
know stripped and refined
um you know your point is well taken but
I think
I think we need to remember that really
very little that we eat now is what it
used to be I mean right I mean
everything oh that's true everything is
hybridized meat's not the same yeah
certainly we're we're breeding we're
breeding animals to be the way that
they're most profitable and have the
highest fat you know now they have very
high fat contents they grow quickly and
so forth so the meat that we eat is not
the same
um even and even you know we can get
into the whole like grass-fed movement
um but even then it's still not the same
as you know what people argue we used to
eat
um and so nothing's the same so you know
again I just have to keep coming back to
what the evidence shows and there are a
lot of different kinds of grains but no
one like at the end of the day we're
talking about grains in their most
intact form I think it would be optimal
to
eat food that's you know as close to
Nature as possible
um you know the whole GMO overlay is
another thing
um but when you just strictly look at
the evidence I think there's a lot of
evidence for just eating whole grains
and I think we also have to remember and
I we're you know I because I'm such a
nutrition nerd and I'm reading stuff
online all the time I like it is very
anchoring for me to go back to my
practice on you know Monday morning at
nine o'clock after reading nutrition
stuff all the time all weekend and then
I mean I do other things too
I do other things what'd you do last
night it's Sunday morning here so what
how you know how did you spend last
night no no that's funny so uh yeah but
I mean I think it's very anchoring to
walk into to talk to real people that
are living their lives and have
stressful lives and go to work and you
know and don't don't necessarily think
about all the stuff that we're talking
about at a really high level and are
just trying to make like affordable
healthy choices for themselves so
they're not gonna you know it would be
great if everyone could have
like some you know artisanal Millet but
I think that at the end of the day like
they have to they're gonna go to the
grocery store in their neighborhood you
know and there's a lot of issues with
food access there too and they're gonna
have to make choices and they're gonna
have to be taught what are the
healthiest choices there so I keep it
pretty simple and I think I try to stay
out of the you know I try to keep
pulling myself back to reality right
right okay so back to the original
question which is like finding
similarities between paleo and vegan but
actually grains is a difference right
right paleo is no grains right
um so so you're saying great so we
talked about grain so in terms of other
similarities I mean no processed food uh
no Dairy you know Whole Foods lots of
vegetables
um I don't know if it's we agree on the
fruit thing right right I that's a good
question that depends on what subset of
paleo you're ascribing to but but I
think overall yeah I mean it's basically
Whole Foods close to their natural state
you know and right and then you can get
granular from that
um but but then kind of you know sort of
sidestepping away from that
um you know I thought it would be
informative to kind of look at some of
the the nutritional trends that are
seemingly getting a lot of traction in
public awareness right now and you know
the number one one thing that always
comes to my mind is like the Time
Magazine cover of you know butter is
back and and you know within that
um within that kind of uh framework is
this idea that you know everything you
heard about saturated fat is incorrect
um you know saturated fat is your new
best friend uh it's really all about
sugar being evil and
um you know eating a high fat low carb
diet is really the way to go I mean
there's a lot of that's kind of what's
in the Zeitgeist at the moment so and
I'm sure that you have patients coming
to you who you know perhaps are are you
know ascribing to this because this is
what they're seeing and hearing right
yeah I mean I think that
as I was saying earlier I think that you
know it's very
um titillating for the media to take a
headline like that right and people
I think a lot of people would love to
hear that butter is back and so it it
makes headlines people you know want to
hear that
um
I think that you know specifically to
address the saturated fat issue and I
know um Garth Davis talked about this a
lot too but the the two studies that
sort of drove those headlines
um
there's been a tremendous amount of
controversy and at the level of
nutrition research and the medical
community about those studies and how
they were designed some sort of gross
errors in data abstraction there were a
lot of concerns raised about industry
ties and
particularly with the dairy
um
industry and there were concerns that
key studies were left out of because
they were meta-analyzes you know they
were they were sort of grouping together
the results of of previously published
studies so they had left out key studies
so and I think I think Garth also said
that uh even under you know the the most
you know sort of positive reading of it
it never said that saturated fat is good
correct right it was correct it wasn't
drawing that conclusion that's right
that's right even if you found no
problems with the methodology and you
took those studies results at face value
you would not be able to conclude that
saturated fat is actually good for you
that is you're absolutely right it was
more a a factor of how or not being as
harmful as we once thought or something
like that right and it's always relative
so whatever it depends you know if
you're eliminating saturated fat from
your diet and first of all nobody has
like bowls of like protein saturated fat
or whatever like they eat food right so
if you're eliminating stuff that has
saturated fat what are you replacing it
with and that's the key question so if
you take a study like that low carb um
there was a low carb low-fat versus
low-fat study published last year about
150 people people and they randomized
them to either eat a low carb diet or a
low-fat diet
the people in the loaf the low fat arm
were replacing the fat with refined
carbohydrates so sure that's not gonna
they're never gonna win out so it's
always a question of that and it's
always a question of how much people
adhere to the actual diet like the low
fat arm didn't they didn't even really
reduce their fat that much about low fat
exactly so um
that's the whole thing too just a you
know sorry for interrupting but there
there's this idea that you know oh for
the last 30 however many years it was
all about low fat well that didn't work
so but it's like no it's just that no
one did it
right yeah right people are always
really surprised to learn that
um you know we I think that if I'm
understanding the numbers correctly as a
percentage of total calories we've
decreased fat over the in like one
percent or some very small number but
we're just eating more calories so in
terms of grams of fat we're we haven't
cut back at all so
um the other big issue with those
saturated fat studies was I mean I think
um Garth mentioned this was that in one
of them you know about half the studies
controlled for people's cholesterol
levels so if you take out the major you
know the major
um
way in which saturated fat creates heart
disease and disease in general if you
control for that and of course you're
not going to find a difference wait so
let me understand that so when you say
control for cholesterol that means that
uh they they selected for people that
were with already within a certain
cholesterol range or I'm not sure so so
um
basically because we know that our blood
levels of cholesterol are highly
correlated with how much saturated fat
we eat
um
in these in in about half or I think
maybe like 40 of the studies that were
included in the big meta-analysis they
had actually statistically adjusted for
people's cholesterol levels so for
example if my total cholesterol was 250
and somebody else's was 120 they
statistically have a way of eliminating
that as a variable I see so therefore if
mine is 250 and yours is 120 and I'm
eating a lot of saturated fat and you're
not but we control for the intermediate
risk factor which is cholesterol levels
in the blood
then it's gonna
you know you're not gonna see you're not
going to necessarily see a big
difference between the two groups I see
interesting
um well one thing you said right there
is is being kind of contested by certain
people out there which is the
relationship between saturated fat
intake and serum cholesterol right so so
in other words uh
dietary cholesterol is not as related to
serum cholesterol as we once thought
this is this idea out there right so
that eating saturated fat doesn't
necessarily impact your cholesterol
levels so so the
so separating out um
dietary saturated fat and dietary
cholesterol that is an important
distinction to make because
dietary cholesterol does not have such a
predictable effect on our blood levels
of cholesterol as saturated fat does
I don't know that there's
too much evidence to support saturated
fat not driving up cholesterol levels
that's pretty much universally
acknowledged so
both in terms of like laboratory like
controlled laboratory experiments where
they Infuse you know where they have
people eat a lot of saturated fat and
they measure their blood levels of
cholesterol you can see it
like in a linear fashion increasing so I
I don't think that there's there's that
much contest around that but yes that
people's responses of dietary
cholesterol is more variable and
the problem is those things go together
in food right so how do you eat dietary
cholesterol and not eat saturated fat
you are those that's my homework that's
my homework I'll try to figure it out I
I you can't exactly so and again like
people don't at the end of the day
people are not choosing Foods based on
like calories from you know saturated
fat they're just choosing food and you
know most people and I don't think it's
a useful construct to talk to people
about please get you know this
percentage of calories from this
nutrient and avoid you know I think we
have to talk to people about foods that
promote health and foods that don't and
take it back to like the the bird's eye
understanding
um well that kind of brings up this
issue of ketosis and sort of setting
aside the fact that like eating this way
probably is
um
probably not getting a lot of fiber well
I guess if you ate a lot of vegetables
perhaps you could but but
um you know I got beat up a little bit
on the internet because I was on a
podcast and I and I happened to say uh
that I wasn't so sure that uh you know
ketosis was a lifestyle that that I
really aspired to and that that you know
it seemed to me to be you know and not
being a scientist or a doctor or any
someone with any kind of medical or or
formal nutrition education
um that my understanding was that
ketosis was kind of uh an emergency
state of the body
um where your body has to kind of you
know scramble and shift the way that it
metabolizes nutrients for energy to you
know sort of accommodate the fact that
your glycogen deprived and that you know
the brain runs on glycogen and that you
know I just didn't think that this
seemed to be something that you know you
should like natural man's not going
around measuring their ketones all the
time like it just doesn't seem to me to
be kind of a healthy way of living and
you know I got blasted by a bunch of oh
you don't know what you're talking about
and you know you don't always understand
what was the CR what what was the
criticism specifically the critters the
criticism was that I didn't know the
first thing about ketosis
I mean it what you've just described is
my medical understanding okay good I'm
glad to hear that so you did pretty well
without any forms
so because listen there's a you know
there's a subset of you know maybe it's
not paleo it gets all confusing but of
the kind of
um you know high fat low carb diet
protocol that a lot of athletes are kind
of getting on board with they're
actually kind of really trying to get
into that ketosis State and and testing
how their body performs athletically
um and you know maybe they're you know
looking at performance goals and not
necessarily at longevity goals or
long-term health goals but
um but you know let me explain to me
what ketosis is and what the kind of
Health implications of kind of being in
that metabolic state are yeah I mean
it's it's an unnatural it's an unnatural
state in that it's not the state that
our bodies were designed to live in
we're designed to closely regulate our
bodies pH
um for optimal cellular function so if
you're depriving yourself of nutrients
that your body has to go into an
emergency state to start using to create
Ketone bodies because you don't have
um you know you you don't have the
nutrients you need that feed your brain
normally that is not a good that is not
an optimal state that is an emergency
State it's it's a it's like a backup
generator
and no one wants to live on like a
backup generator that's not an optimal
State now I can't tell you I don't think
I've looked at I don't even know if
there are studies but I haven't looked
at studies showing that in the very
short term how that affects athletic
performance I can't really speak to that
but yeah the idea is that it helps with
being fat adapted okay so if you're an
endurance athlete it's all about
efficiency and the more that you can
become uh Reliant upon your your fat
stores for fuel as opposed to glycogen
then you're you can go longer and Etc
right I mean I would question you know
all I can tell you is that when you see
human beings in ketosis and you take
care of people in ketotic States they
don't feel well they're very very sick
and maybe this is just a milder form but
um I can only really speak to like
long-term Optimal Health there's there's
no way that that can be and can produce
an optimal situation so when you say
like they're they're very sick like what
is that sickness yeah I mean they have
what are those symptoms yeah I mean they
have mental fogginess they feel nauseous
they're often dehydrated
um you know they're just uh you know
they're fatigued so again because of the
type of practice that I have I'm not
necessarily talking about if you're
doing it in a milder form for athletic
performance but I'm talking about more
extreme cases but
I just can't imagine that that's a good
long-term strategy and again just again
taking it back to the big picture the
foods that put you in that state you
know or depriving yourself of the foods
to get yourself in that state is not
evidence-based at all
interesting so uh
yeah because there's like there's what
are the names of is it not David Pearl
monitor but uh Professor Tim Knox are
you familiar with his work which is one
of the people out there that talks a lot
about this
um all right anyway so let's get back to
like your practice and
um we kind of diverted way off the
timeline there but but uh yeah you know
we we where we left it off was that you
had gone to this conference and uh okay
and you were so inspired and then you
began to sort of incorporate some of
these tools that you learned into
helping your patients but at this point
were you completely plant-based yourself
or is that what pushed you into kind of
you know adopting the lifestyle in your
your own personal life or yeah no I mean
I think I'm glad you came back to that
um
so around 2007 I want to say
um
a shift like a like a switch went off
for me around
um
awareness of the foods that I was eating
and what what happened like what was
going on for me to be able to eat like
cheese and yogurt and um you know as I
mentioned I'd already had I was already
a vegetarian but I think I've I really
internalized the information around you
know what actually necessarily has to
happen from to animals for me to eat
dairy and cheese and
um and I think that an eggs and I and I
think when you I still believe that for
a lot of people if you actually
internalize that information if you
actually like don't shut it out and you
take it in and you you see it it is very
hard to eat those foods like that's the
bottom line and I was I was like that
right well the system's set up to
prevent you from understanding that they
work very hard to create that Iron
Curtain very hard yeah yeah I mean
curtain's coming down
yeah not in North Carolina well there's
a lot of I mean there's for every you
know for every new AG gag law there's a
new drone that's like you know with a
GoPro on it have you watched that stuff
yeah Will Potter is like a hero and he's
amazing Mark DeVries and his films
um his drone stuff is is great but so
yeah switch went off for me I
internalized the information and I just
felt like you know I mean I think Gene
Bauer really says it best and you know I
don't know if your listeners I know you
had him on the podcast but he's the um
founder one of the founders of Farm
Sanctuary I mean he really says it best
when you you know the point is living in
alignment with your values right and I'm
not
to me the values are very simple and
it's the same values I'm practicing when
I'm a doctor you know I'm I've I value
compassion and I value connection and I
value not causing harm and to me it's
like why am I separating that out I mean
we're all interconnected I'm not I don't
want to cause harm to the planet I don't
want to cause harm to other living
beings so
to me that was that was a very Sentinel
moment I made a another yet another
dietary shift and went plant-based flesh
vegan
um
but again I didn't I wasn't I didn't
incorporate it into my practice until
after that this conference that I've
been talking about and so I feel like
for me now I feel like for me now since
like going to that conference and
realizing that you know I have this
passion about
this way of eating that is you know when
you take like the the health aspect the
sustainability and the environment and
you take
you know compassion and and concern for
other living beings and you mesh them
all together this is really the the only
way of eating that
brings that all together so
for me
like you talk about Finding Ultra right
for me this was Finding Ultra this was
my ultra you found your Ultra I found my
ultra
um it was a long time coming but I think
it was for me too
I think you actually got a couple of
years on me but um but no I mean for me
it's like it's renewed my my passion
around
practicing medicine and and around life
in general I feel like
I my purpose I'm authentic I'm living
like there's no dissonance between how I
the choices I'm making and how what I'm
putting out there in the world yeah
that's a really cool thing when you can
kind of like I feel that now too and if
you told me many years ago like that
that was even something that is
important like I would have been like
what are you talking about but there
really is something intangible
um but very real about
aligning your values with your actions
you know and when you don't have that
dissonance or that like you know when
you're not when you're when you're
saying one thing and doing another and
we all to some extent because we live in
the modern world and nobody's perfect
there's some level of that in all of us
right you know and it's like right you
know I fly on airplanes and I drive a
car and I do all these kinds of things
that harm the planet you know it's like
I'm not standing up on a pedestal like
I'm some you know you know Superior
being I'm very much not but but when you
when I make that choice to say well this
is important to me and I'm going to make
sure that my actions line up with that
like there's a self-esteem that comes
with that and there's I don't know
there's something about that that really
changes the quality of your life it
absolutely does and I am far from
perfect either and I think that
recognizing that is actually
um is actually beneficial because you
know it doesn't mean it doesn't mean do
nothing it just means get started you
know just get started just just see like
what are the changes that are possible
for you to start with that are in
alignment with your values and you don't
have to you can decide where you're
going to draw the line
um for me the lines at one place and um
and I feel great about living within
that line and what I think is really
cool about it is that it's not like
making that choice has a negative impact
on some other aspect of your life like
you can be an athlete right you can do
what's right for the planet and you can
take out an insurance policy against
disease you can even reverse diseases
that you've had or things that have been
you know
bothersome for you your whole life
whether it's like skin problems like all
these sorts of things there so it's like
yeah maybe you crave a certain food that
you like to eat like that's basically
the biggest negative aspect of the whole
thing but if you kind of can weather
through that yeah you know short-term
discomfort and get to the other side of
it there's a certain Freedom that comes
with that that I think is a really
beautiful thing and it's and it's
absolutely and it's beyond
um
it's actually been pretty eye-opening in
terms of like the just the diversity of
foods that I eat now compared to before
I went plant-based slash vegan
um people don't they don't believe that
I know I don't know why they don't they
don't buy it
well I mean again I can only speak for
myself but I and you know when I when I
talk to my patients and I I do a lot of
um dietary surveys I mean informally
when I because it's such a big part of
my practice and when I hear what people
eat there's a lot of repetition
a lot of repetition
um
so I think an argument can be made that
you can actually broaden right like
people think they're eating a larger
diversity of foods than they actually
are right they're having
eggs in the morning they're having a
turkey sandwich you know a lunch they're
having a roasted chicken at night and
then they're repeating it like every
other day or even every day right well
let's talk about your patients a little
bit like uh you know what is the you
would kind of mention like the typical
things that you see elevated blood
pressure
um you know diabetes obesity heart
disease things like that like
walk me through some of the success
stories that you've had through the you
know sort of the non-invasive uh you
know dietary
Council that you're giving yeah so
so again one of the great things about
being an internist is that you are
looking at all the organ systems and the
whole person at once
um from like Mental Health on down to
like their feet you know I mean
everything so
when I there'll be days when I will
I'll have a patient with you know
constipation
um like just general fatigue bad sleep
um high blood pressure and wants to lose
weight like that's basically everybody
and and I'll it's it's kind of one stop
shopping in the sense that I will
prescribe the same way of eating for all
of those conditions right because it all
of those things get better with eating a
whole food plant-based diet and so I
think some specific examples
um
and and these are happening all the time
and it's so rewarding to see I you know
I'll meet a new patient I met and this
uh this gentleman from Mexico
um last December and um checked his
cholesterol and I think his his LDL
which is the bad form of cholesterol was
around 140. and so I called him up and I
you know I said hey you know you've
gotta gotta make some changes and here's
what I'd recommend that you do
and I told him to
basically cut back on animal products
and focus more on plant foods and I have
a speech I have a way of saying that and
I you know I can do it across a bunch of
different languages now and how many
languages do you speak no I don't sorry
Through The Interpreter oh okay
no I speak Spanish in English well what
is the general like like like the
strategy that you employ to connect
because people will say and doctors will
say well I can tell them to eat better
but they're not going to do it like
that's the conventional wisdom right
yeah I have not had that experience at
all I mean sure there's there's lots of
people that aren't ready to make changes
but there are lots of people that are
and just need like they just need
support and they some of them are it's
as basic as they just need the
information like
um so my strategy is
um you know I I kind of follow this
motivational interviewing approach which
is a you know a way of practicing where
you're kind of meeting the person where
they're at so that's my first question
always is like do you are you interested
in hearing about some things that you
can change in your food choices that
might help you feel better so depending
on how interested they are then I start
giving out the information and then I
start figuring out like what you know I
strategize with them like what are they
ready to start working on and I know
there's a whole you know when you listen
to podcasts and you talk to experts you
know there's a whole thing in the
plant-based Community about whether you
should take small steps or Dive In and
that's a really interesting
dichotomy to me but
in my reality I am helping people take
small steps because it's not it's not
everybody that's ready to dive in and so
maybe one day they will be ready but for
now even with some small changes they
can start getting benefits so
so yeah I'll kind of identify you know
what are you here are some things I
think you could work on which one of
these broad categories are you ready to
start working on yeah
and then we kind of take it from there
so
I have a bunch of tools and right I
think small steps is great because like
if you told people
look you got to do this completely right
now 100 and then a week later they mess
up then they're just gonna give up right
you know and if you're talking about the
goal being sustainability like give them
one thing to master right you know and
then let them get on top of that and
then they'll create that connect oh that
actually made me feel better and I'm
drinking almond milk now and not you
know not dairy and like I can do it
right so then they feel empowered yeah
they feel empowered to do the next thing
you know that is that is the basis of my
practice and I've seen it work
um I I think the argument for diving
right in is also compelling in the sense
that you know when you when you're in
when you're in an environment where you
do have a lot of support like in like in
John mcdougall's program or something
where you're actually like you're
immersed you're in an immersion
situation people feel so much better so
quickly when they transition that
um that might keep them going but I
don't have the I don't have those
resources so for me this is a more right
unless somebody's just hugely internally
motivated right and there are those
people or their their health is in such
disrepair that's that it's really
critical right but people need a lot of
help because I mean as as we all know
our our food system and our society does
not make it easy for people to make this
switch I mean you really have to
um be proactive and aggressive about
making the changes
okay so high cholesterol oh my God down
yeah so yeah I mean it's just one
example so no it was it was really great
because I um you know I said here's what
I want you to do I want you to crowd you
know I use the crowding out thing a lot
you know where instead of making it so
negative like stop eating this stop
eating that I just say you know before
you're like can you eat a bowl of you
know a bean soup or lentil soup before
whatever you would normally eat for
dinner and just start crowding it out
gradually
so I gave him all that advice and
um I said come back in two months and
you know we'll check your cholesterol so
a couple months later his results came
in like popped up in my computer queue
and I looked at them and his LDL was 80.
so it was one went from 140 to 80. yeah
almost in half and I just thought and I
looked at my note I like started opening
my note to remember what I had done and
I thought well which Statin did I put
him on because this is a great response
to a Statin you know and then I looked
at my note and I I and I realized I
hadn't put him on any drugs at all I was
so it was so incredible
um not just and that and that he I mean
that was very simple dietary advice and
he he was ready to run with it and did
it right like he did it though like
that's the thing right right like he was
he was right he was a partner in this
relationship and did the work as if you
know you're the coach and he's the
athlete like you know the coach can say
whatever but if the athlete doesn't show
up for workout and there's and there's a
lot of great reasons why people don't
show up for for their workout you know I
mean there's I I take care of people
that are you know facing a huge number
of barriers like people that you know
live in the shelter system or people
that are dealing with you know single
parent they're single parents or their
fixed incomes and so I feel like my role
and what I can best offer to my patients
is to be a troubleshooter and to be
um obviously as non-judgmental as I can
and
um kind of help them work through it
well that brings up another important
thing which is you know this unfortunate
situation that we're in where uh you
know Wellness is kind of being aligned
with elitism you know and particularly
plant-based or being vegan it's like oh
well if you're going to do that then
you're going to be spending all your
money at Whole Foods and you're going to
be spending all day in the kitchen
creating these crazy recipes and you
know who can afford that and who's got
the time and yet here you are you know
treating you know for the most part like
you know an underprivileged community of
people who are in dire health and who
don't have the means and and most likely
don't have the time to you know live
that lifestyle so how do they navigate
it and what's your perspective on that
yeah I mean I I actually specifically
tell people that you don't have to shop
at a like a high-end grocery store to
get you know healthy food and I go as
far as and I have a little more time
when I'm running my in the Obesity
clinic setting than I do in my normal
primary care practice but I will
literally like we'll sit down we'll go
on Google Maps and we'll we'll just
figure stuff out and you know I would
love to have like a health coach working
with me who could do that but for now
it's me and I think the message is that
you know we can
you know we can brainstorm this together
and there are definitely always options
there are always options yeah it's
really similar to what um Robert
osfeld's doing yeah I'm sure you know
yeah yeah we're friends yeah it's great
and yeah he's now he has those health
coaches now because he's created this
program so yeah I could see you doing
something like that yeah I can't tell
you what it um how good it feels to be
able to connect with people on this
level because when you talk to people
about food and lifestyle in general but
when you talk to people about food you
start you have a window into their life
that I don't think you really have when
you're just saying like hi how you doing
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna get out my
prescription pad and um are you taking
your medicines or not it's like very
binary like this is just an expansive
understanding of people and you get to
connect with them in a way that you
might not otherwise
so somebody's on a super low budget like
what is the you know what's the first
thing like what are the first things
you're telling them to go to the like
are you telling to buy certain things in
bulk or like how does that work yeah I
mean like it's a it's a cross product of
time money and access right so
you know people that have that don't
have a lot of money but have more time
have certain options and then we work on
the access together because they're
almost always is access they just don't
people don't realize
um but if you're limited on time and
money then it gets a little harder it's
still not impossible
um
people have this perception that like if
you can't buy organic like Farmers
Market fruits and vegetables that you
shouldn't bother that it's worse for you
to be eating normal and I I don't think
I don't think that's true and I don't
think the data support that
um so I talk to people about you know
especially in the winter getting frozen
frozen vegetables they're not expensive
they don't go bad keep them in your
freezer and then you don't have an
excuse for not putting them on your
plate
um you know beans and legumes like
lentils and chickpeas
um are not only like culturally very
applicable for across a wide range of
cultures but they're obviously pretty
cheap especially in the dried form
um and people are spending people are
spending money on things that that don't
promote Health like soda and Snapple and
obviously you know and
frozen meals and Deli San Deli like
turkey sandwiches McDonald's Wendy's and
right you know whatever right right and
and and you know obviously those are
artificially cheap and that's another
whole conversation
um because of subsidies but I talked to
people about you know just start
diverting some of that money
um
and maybe they won't be able to afford
the most expensive vegetables out of
season but right it is progress and
people can make huge strides in their
house in terms of just starting to
navigate a little bit pushing the needle
we gotta wrap it up here in a few
minutes but there's a couple things I
still want to ask you and I think it
would be really helpful for people if
you could just leave them with you know
I don't know two three like really
simple but like powerful you know
prescriptions for
living healthier
sure
I mean I think that I think the number
one would be to
um
to to find the joy in
eating in a way and keep yourself open
to eating in a way that's
sustainable and compassionate and health
promoting so I know that's not that's
like at the high level that's not a
practical tip but that's what drives me
and again that
um
that I think is the message that I'd
like to spread
when you
think about eating across the diversity
of colors of the rainbow and that's what
I tell my patients a lot too I think you
can get a lot of mileage out of that
because you know as long as it's not
Skittles you know if you're eating it's
a rainbow yeah yeah I mean I use that
you know that pcrm poster all the time
with people but that gets you a lot of
mileage because if you're doing if
you're doing a diversity of colors and
fruits and vegetables in the course of
three or four days you're getting a lot
of fruits and vegetables or you're
getting more than you were before
um
finding
um you know focusing
foods that are as close to their natural
state as possible and foods that come
from the ground and from trees
um those are the foods that we know
promote longevity and reduce disease
these are just all crazy ideas I mean
who are you you know and there's crazy
there are crazy ideas out there
um
and you know there's I I love this isn't
this is by the way the same message that
I give when I give nutrition lectures to
doctors you know and you you can't
believe
um some of the ideas that are out there
because
people have just have not been trained
in nutrition at all doctors and so
um it's a it's a powerful message and I
think it keeping it simple and yeah well
I'm really excited about what you're
doing with within the profession you
know educating other doctors and and
medical professionals I think that's
super powerful thank you that's exciting
and you know more people should be doing
that you know it's like if the medical
schools aren't going to do it somebody's
got to take responsibility for it and
the fact that you're yeah investing in
that I think is really a special thing
thank you it's fun yeah it's great and
you know at the top level like the first
thing you mentioned just you know living
living more sustainably eating more
sustainably I mean it's just incumbent
upon all of us too
uh you know really grab that mantle of
educating ourselves about where our food
comes from like however you're eating
you know what I mean like we deserve to
know where our food's coming from get
interested in that learn how to read a
nutrition facts label and you know find
out who these companies are that are
producing these Foods how they're
producing them how they're shipped and
manufactured and packaged and marketed
and all of that because that knowledge
is power and that power will help drive
your consumer choices and
you know a lot of people feel we feel
disenfranchised you know we feel like we
can't make a difference or we just let's
just do what everyone else is doing and
live this kind of Matrix lifestyle and
it's easy to do that it's easy to do
that you know and and I did it for most
of my life but when you finally say no
I'm going to you know I'm going to do
what's best for me and I'm going to
educate myself and make the right choice
for myself it's incredibly empowering
and enlightening and it will it will
change your life and it can change the
life of the people around you and your
loved ones in in doing so right well
said yeah I mean it's really powerful
and you know I just encourage everybody
to go on their own you know version of
your adventure and my adventure and have
their own experience with it yeah all
right so I'm gonna uh wrap this up with
the final question it's the same
question that I asked Garth at the end
so if you listen to that I did but I
don't remember I don't remember well you
will remember in a moment uh if you were
Surgeon General oh what would you do
well yeah oh I loved his answer I loved
his answer and so
um
well I don't know that the Surgeon
General has the power to do this listen
we're imagining a crazy Universe we're
actually like the the this official like
I could actually do things okay sounds
sounds like a great deal sign me up
um I think the number one thing would be
to
um to to stop artificially
subsidizing the foods that are least
healthy for our
for us right I mean I think that is
where the number one driver you know
that's one of the first things I would
do because people don't realize how much
their food should cost
um and that doesn't take into account
like the health care costs that are that
stem from those Foods so that would be
the first thing um have you read uh
David Simon's book me Anonymous one of
my favorite books I've ever read yeah
and for people that are listening I had
him on the podcast it was quite a while
ago I don't remember what episode number
it is but I'll put a link up in the show
notes to that but basically his whole
book is really looks into how subsidies
drive you know economic that the
economic machine behind kind of fast
food and all of that so in other words
that you know 99 cent McDonald's burger
is really like a seven dollar burger
because of everything that goes into it
politically exactly and and then there's
also the you know the stepchild of that
is the advertising you know the
advertising and so
um
that we're actually our taxes are going
to advertising for those foods not just
paying at the level of subsidizing the
production of the food but actually
paying for the advertisement for that
food so you know you'll be you know
watching TV and you'll see in at you
know you'll see an ad for like a
pepperoni cheese pizza and then the next
ad is for you know Viagra and it's like
we can't you know we really have to
start making the connection
um so that would be the first that would
be the first rung
um and and I think that I would also
um I think that there has to be a way to
start educating people about what the
healthiest foods are and to use an
evidence-based approach
because there's a lot of evidence like I
said for a common consensus and
um
I would use that platform to get the
message out in a way that's really clear
and get people to understand that you
know it's not it may not necessarily be
in the headlines and just
have a broad consensus around that
that's a good answer
I think that's a beautiful way to wrap
it up thank you so yeah thanks so much
for
spending some time with me today thank
you your work is really inspiring and um
and I really appreciate what you do and
I hope that you continue to do it and I
hope that your work inspires many others
to follow in your footsteps thank you so
thanks likewise thanks for being here
peace
plants
[Music]
foreign